bonjour olivier oui nous bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être ce matin en direct avec
nous sur rt france pour parler de ces
médecins intérimaires qui sont reçus
aujourd'hui par olivier ferrand la loi
encadrant leur salaire a été reporté
qu'en pensez vous
ce qui est incontestable en fait ces
deux il faut recadrer la peur c'est que
il ya des promesses qui ont été faites
alors qu'on était en état de crise
sanitaire et ses promesses ne sont pas à
la hauteur de ce que les uns et les
autres attendions le président d'havas
et des salaires oui oui oui je parle des
salaires et des conditions de travail en
général cet aspect coutellier en fait si
on n'a pas une politique de salaires sur
l'hôpital à l'évidence on ne sera pas
attractif et on sera pas fidélisant et
on se sauve à ce qu'on va rester dans
une situation que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui où nous avons des postes
vacants nous sommes dans l'incapacité
aujourd'hui de ré ouvrir des lits qui
ont été fermés faute de personnel que ce
soit du personnel médical qui soit dit
personnel non médical soignant ouvriers
et administratifs donc si le
gouvernement et ça semble être le choix
qu'il fait n'entend pas ou ne répondent
pas à cette demande on va avoir une
inflation des
des intérimaires dans nos dans nos
services et continuer de
givre ce que l'on connaît déjà des
services hospitaliers services publics
qui travaille essentiellement où il ya
un an jour n'est plus d'intérimaires
chkili a de titulaire donc il est grand
temps de recadrer cette affaire il est
grand temps de répondre aux
revendications ou justes revendications
des hospitaliers et visiblement ce n'est
pas le chemin que prend le gouvernement
est pas ce que vous en faites vous dites
au lieu d'encadrer les salaires des
intérimaires il vaudrait mieux fidéliser
les médecins qui sont à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui à l'évidence oui c'est vous
savez c'est la loi du marché en fait un
et je crois que les gens sont ils y sont
attachées au gouvernement comme dans
beaucoup de gouvernements
il fallait pas attendre longtemps pour
que les hospitaliers comprennent les
règles du jeu pendant la crise coli dont
on avait des collègues qui venait
intérimaire qui gagnait le double de ce
que l'on gagnait nous titulaire des
services donc
aujourd'hui on a une vraie fuite des
personnels de l'hôpital public et on a
une inflation des intérimaires donc il
faut recadrer les choses si le marché
des sites que le salaire des soignants
peut être largement on peut valoriser ça
semble être le cas aujourd'hui il est
temps de le faire et effets pervers
c'est que beaucoup de médecins qui
étaient salariés à l'hôpital public
devient d'intérimaires aussi c'est
exactement ça exactement ça c'est vrai
pour les médecins c'est vrai pour les
personnes nommées d'icônes des
infirmiers notamment aujourd'hui sur la
seule assistance publique parce que
c'est l'établissement que je connais le
mieux on à 1074 postes vacants
d'infirmier on n'arrive pas à les
recruter et pourtant on en a formé ses
infirmiers là ils sont où ces infirmiers
ils sont dans les centres de vaccination
on les paye largement plus on est payé à
l'hôpital et ils sont dans les bois de
l'intérimaire où ils peuvent faire des
vacations dans les mêmes services qu'à
l'hôpital dans nos établissements et
payer le double de ce que l'on est donc
cette fuite là
existe elle est forte et la concurrence
que l'on croyait dans les établissements
privés elle est plutôt dans les boîtes
d'intérim aujourd'hui est-ce que la
crise sanitaire a accentué ce problème
et l'obligation aussi du pain sanitaire
de la vaccination pour les soignants
c'est clairement il ya eu un problème de
communication du gouvernement vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble de la population mais de
des hospitaliers en particulier et
beaucoup de spitz ali n'ont pas compris
cette ce qu'ils ont vécu comme une
stigmatisation quand l'obligation
vaccinale leur a été faite et qu'elle
n'a pas été fait pour l'ensemble de la
population donc ça ça n'a pas facilité
le dialogue ou la compréhension des
hospitaliers vis-à-vis du gouvernement
et puis il ya les conditions de travail
que l'on a connues pendant la crise la
première vague où on était à poil un
haut-fond à la guerre comme disait le
président de la république on n'avait
pas de masque on me disait que ça
servait à rien aujourd'hui on est tous
parce que je n'arrive pas à s'en sortir
on n'avait pas de quoi se protéger on
n'avait pas suffisamment de médicaments
n'avaient pas suffisamment les matériels
on nous a promis à ce moment là le monde
d'après que ce serait différent que il
ya des secteurs de l'économie qui allait
échapper à la logique marchande on
pensait notamment à la santé c'est pas
le cas le monde d'après c'est le monde
d'avant en pliant est tous allés les
hospitaliers l'ont bien mesuré et se
disent bien quitte à jouer le jeu on va
jouer avec leurs règles et puis on va
faire monter on va faire monter les
tarifs mais c'est ça
le fait qu'ils soient reçus cet après
midi par par olivier ferrand ça va
changer quoi selon vous pas grand chose
je crois que monsieur lé rond a reçu
plein de monde et des hospitaliers à
gogo depuis plus d'un an et demi a eu le
fameux secure qui allait régler toutes
là toute la difficulté de
de l'hôpital public et du champ
sanitaire et sociale mais ça n'a pas été
le cas
l'éléphant accouché d'une souris des
revalorisations salariales ne sont pas à
la hauteur 183 euros pour tous et des
difficultés de la mise en place dans les
dans les différentes catégories de
revalorisation de carrière elle
revalorisation salariale tout ça n'est
pas n'est pas de bons présages et les
choses vont beaucoup plus vite que
monsieur vers en imagine merci beaucoup
olivier youinou nouveau précision et on
va suivre évidemment l'actualité liée à
la réception de ces médecins intérimaire
par olivier ferrand tout à leur merci